frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zu hart und furchtbar die letzten sechs
Monate waren
so stolz können wir glaube ich sein
nicht nur wie Menschen in der Ukraine
auch unsere Friedensordnung verteidigt
haben stolz und dankbar sondern auch wie
unser Land vor allen Dingen die Menschen
in diesem Land zusammengestanden haben
und ohne Wenn und Aber Solidarität für
diejenigen gezeigt haben die aus der
Ukraine flüchten mussten dieser
Zusammenhalt diese Geschlossenheit das
war und ist unsere gemeinsame Stärke und
ja ich habe heute morgen in der Debatte
sehr genau zugehört da waren ja auch so
ein paar Zwischentöne und manche haben
es deutlich ausgesprochen
tun wir genug und in jeder Minute für
den Frieden diplomatisch zu kämpfen ja
wir probieren das jede Minute aber wir
müssen gerade auch in Gedenken an
Michael Gorbatschow und vergegenwärtigen
dass wir nicht mit Michael Gorbatschow
in dieser Situation verhandeln sondern
mit dem russischen Präsidenten und es
geht in diesen Zeiten darum
Menschenleben zu retten es geht in
diesen Zeiten nicht darum ob die
deutsche Außenministerin eine Headline
hat dass sie auch mal mit jemandem in
Russland telefoniert hat und deswegen
setzen wir all unsere diplomatische
Kraft in diesen sechs Monaten da rein
Menschenleben zu retten hinter den
Kulissen über die Vereinten Nationen
weil sie sind in diesen Zeiten der
einzige Schlüssel der überhaupt
Millimeter von Frieden bewegen kann
und daher unterstütze ich unterstützt
mein Team unterstützt die deutsche
Bundesregierung der deutsche
Bundeskanzler vor allen Dingen die
Organisationen die überhaupt noch Zugang
haben das Internationale Komitee des
Roten Kreuzes um humanitäre
fluchtkorridore zu ermöglichen die IAEO
um zu gewährleisten dass es nicht noch
eine Nuklearkatastrophe gibt das ist
Diplomatie die wirkt nicht schnelle
große Schlagzeilen sondern hinter den
Kulissen zu arbeiten für die Menschen
denn es geht allein um die Menschenleben
die hier gefährdet sind
und daher bitte ich Sie wir leben zum
Glück in einen freien Land wo jeder
sagen kann was er will demonstrieren
kann für wen oder was oder gegen was er
will aber lassen Sie uns es dem
russischen Regime nicht so einfach
machen in diesen Momenten unsere größte
Stärke anzugreifen und das ist unser
Zusammenhalt das ist der Moment in dem
wir gemeinsam stehen und ich finde es
wirklich mehr als zynisch das hier und
das passiert ja nicht nur im heutigen
Tag sondern bei Social Media noch von
einigen anderen Akteuren die das nicht
im Hohen Haus sagen aber ganz ganz
schnell auf Facebook oder Twitter
verbreiten
Menschen die sich in Deutschland Sorgen
darüber machen wie sie ihre Strom- oder
Gasrechnung bezahlen können gegen
Menschen in Afrika auszuspielen die
nicht wissen wie sie ihre Kinder in den
nächsten Tagen versorgen können oder
auch
Gasrechnung auszuspielen gegen
ukrainische Mütter und Kinder die jeden
Tag nicht sehnlicher erhoffen als
endlich ihre Ehemänner wieder in die
Arme zu schließen das halte ich wirklich
gesagt für mehr als zynisch das ist
keine
Menschenrechtspolitik sondern das ist
Unterstützung für denjenigen der hier
nicht nur die Ukraine angreift sondern
die Regel basierte internationale
Ordnung und wir müssen uns einfach
vergegenwärtigen dieser Krieg wird auf
verschiedenen Ebenen gespielt nicht nur
mit Waffen nicht nur mit Gas und Öl
sondern auch mit Lügen und falschen
narrativen und ja da werden Videos
sinnenfremde zusammengeschnitten das
gehört irgendwie zu unserem Job dazu das
aushalten zu können aber und deswegen
appelliere ich so eindringlich an alle
die an internationales Recht die Anjas
die Stärke des Recht und nicht das
rechte stärkeren Glaubens fallen sie
darauf nicht rein sondern werben Sie
dafür dass wir es gemeinsam erkennen
weil heute trifft es jemanden von uns
und morgen trifft diese Propaganda
andere die schwächer sind als wir und
wir haben das doch schon mal erlebt zu
Zeiten als viele Millionen Flüchtlinge
nach Europa gekommen sind
seinen ehrenamtliche Bürgermeister
zurückgetreten weil sie gesagt haben wir
können das nicht mehr ertragen das ist
der Moment wo wir gemeinsam
zusammenstehen müssen und zwar ganz oben
begonnen bei denjenigen hier im
Parlament die alle Mittel haben die alle
Kanäle haben die alle Öffentlichkeit
haben dieser falschen Propaganda
entgegenzutreten
und das heißt eben nicht nur Fake News
entgegenzutreten sondern und ja das ist
die Aufgabe der deutschen
Bundesregierung diejenigen die sich zu
Recht Sorgen machen was passiert in
diesem Winter was passiert mit der
Stromrechnung wenn ich sie nicht
bezahlen kann den zu helfen und das
haben wir heute eindringlich diskutiert
zu helfen über ein soziales
Entlastungspaket aber es heißt eben auch
dass wenn wir uns nicht spalten lassen
dieser Zusammenhalt nicht nur nach ihnen
gilt sondern vor allen Dingen nach außen
gilt und deswegen wird es nicht reichen
wenn eu-nate und G7 in den nächsten
Monaten weiter so geschlossen
zusammenstehen wie bisher sondern das
geht darum dass die 141 Staaten und
ehrlich gesagt werden es mehr und nicht
weniger wenn wir hinter den Kulissen
reden dass die weiter zusammenstehen
können und daher ist so wichtig dass im
Entlastungspaket mit der 1 Milliarde für
globale Ernährung aber erst recht in
diesem Haushalt deutlich gemacht wird
wir unterstützen jetzt erst recht wo
unsere
europäische Friedensordnung angegriffen
wird jetzt erst recht unterstützen wir
international diejenigen die am meisten
Unterstützung brauchen
und ich möchte an der Stelle ist auch
sagen und deswegen wir haben es heute im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss diskutiert ist es
mir so wichtig dass wir es uns im Saal
nicht zu einfach machen
ich kann auf der einen Seite als
deutsche Außenministerin als
Bundesregierung aber eigentlich als
gemeinsames Europa schwer an andere
Länder appellieren bitte helft uns bei
der Verteidigung unser europäischen
Friedensordnung und dann zu sagen aber
wir haben gerade nicht Kraft oder
Ressource uns weiter im Saal zu
engagieren in einer vernetzten Welt
hängt alles miteinander zusammen und ja
die Sicherheit unserer Soldatinnen und
Soldaten ist zentral aber es ist eben
auch zentral dass wir gerade in diesem
Moment verlässliche Partner sind und
auch daran arbeiten wir gemeinsam
und in dem Sinne möchte ich mich bei all
denjenigen bedanken die konstruktiv
überlegen wie können wir in diesen
Zeiten wo wir projizieren müssen auch
klar prioritäre Prioritäten setzen bei
der humanitären Hilfe aber eben auch
weiter bei der auswärtigen Kultur und
Bildungspolitik und auch hier nämlich
sehr genau war dass einige von ihnen mir
mitgegeben haben passen Sie auf dass das
Geld nicht deutlich runtergeht aber das
bedeutet insgesamt dass wir uns deutlich
machen müssen dass in einer der größten
außenpolitischen Krisen nicht im
Außenbereich und in deren
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit gekürzt
werden darf sondern dass wir in dem
Bereich die Gelder auch in Zukunft
sicherstellen müssen denn ein Kollege
hat es mir sehr deutlich gesagt vom
afrikanischen Kontinent ihr braucht doch
keine Partner die euch nur gefallen
wollen ihr wollt doch überzeugte Partner
haben und überzeugen können wir nur wenn
wir weiter zusammenarbeiten nicht nur
zwischen Außenministerien sondern in der
auswärtigen Kultur und Bildungspolitik
in Forschungslaboren und in
journalisteneinrichtungen das ist jetzt
der Moment wo wir international
zusammenstehen müssen das ist der Moment
gemeinsam für eine Welt zu kämpfen in
der Regeln und Recht gelten und nicht
macht Lügen und Willkür und das ist auch
der beste Schutz für unsere Demokratie
und einen starken Sozialstaat herzlichen
Dank
bundesaußenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock
hier zum Auftakt der Beratung für ihren
Einzelplan
der die Außenpolitik natürlich
vor allem auch die Entlastung eine
Milliarde globale Ernährung ist
angesprochen worden auch für die
auswärtige Kulturpolitik da wird es noch
mal Verhandlungen geben für humanitäre
Hilfe aber vor allem Politik und
Diplomatie spielen natürlich hier eine
Rolle Jürgen hart für die Union und das
ist das Zeichen der Zeit das
außenpolitische Fragen für auch für die
Menschen wahrscheinlich jetzt auch die
uns zuschauen ganz vorne stehen was das
Interesse angeht ich möchte für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sagen dass wir als demokratische
Opposition ganz klar unsere
Verpflichtung sehen einen konstruktiven
Beitrag zum Gelingen der deutschen
Außenpolitik zu leisten das hat gute
Tradition hier in diesem Haus und die
möchten wir auch aufrechterhalten
wir erwarten im Gegenzug und dazu werde
ich gleich einige Gedanken vortragen
natürlich Verlässlichkeit in der
Zusammenarbeit was die Informationen was
die Position der Bundesregierung angeht
damit wir uns auch entsprechend darauf
einstellen können und dass wir auf eine
fairen sachlichen Ebene miteinander die
diskutieren und an dieser Stelle liebe
Frau Bundesministerin muss sich schon
sagen sie haben jetzt gerade einen wie
ich finde unterstützend werden Appell
gegen Reduzierungen im auswärtigen Etat
vorgetragen wenn ich mir die Zahlen
gucke die das Bundeskabinett vermutlich
auch mit ihrer Stimme beschlossen hat
gibt es da Luft nach oben humanitäre
Hilfe ist entsprechend deutlich
niedriger angesetzt auch andere Bereiche
es wird an uns nicht liegen
müssten sie die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Koalition ansprechen wir werden
bereit sein hier Mittel zusätzlich zu
bereitzustellen aber den Vorwurf den
Vorschlag muss die Regierung machen
so ich
[Applaus]
komme auf das
Hauptthema Ukraine zu sprechen
wir haben bei uns in Deutschland in
diesen Wochen und Monaten vor dem
Hintergrund da steigenden Energiepreise
der Inflation der Sorgen der Menschen
eine Debatte ob er den wirklich alles
tun
diesen Konflikt möglichst einzuheben ich
behaupte es gibt nur einen Weg diesen
Konflikt wirklich einzuheben nämlich das
ist die Doppelstrategie aus starker
knallharter Sanktionspolitik einerseits
die die russische Wirtschaft massiv
trifft und dem militärischen Widerstand
der Ukraine andererseits und die
Bemühungen müssen darauf gerichtet sein
dass Sanktionsregime noch lückenloser
noch besser zu machen Stichwort achte
sektionspaket vielleicht auch die Zahl
der Personen die gelistet sind noch mal
deutlich auszuweiten und auf der anderen
Seite eben die Ukraine die Lage zu
versetzen sich gegen diesen russischen
Angriff erfolgreich zu wehren denn nur
wenn Putin
zu der Einschätzung kommt dass die
Fortsetzung des Krieges für ihn ein
größeres Risiko darstellt als in
irgendeine vernünftige faire Verhandlung
einzutreten wie der Krieg beendet werden
kann nur dann werden wir Erfolg haben
alles was die tatfrieden aus potenzicht
aus einer Position der vermeintlichen
und tatsächlichen Stärke herauskommt
wird nicht zum Erfolg führen und die
Menschen die glauben dass wenn wir dem
Diktator in Moskau auch nur einfach
zugeben würden Kompromiss machen würden
und ihm etwas geben würden von dem was
er haben will also zum Beispiel
akzeptieren würden dass er einen Teil
der Ukraine annektiert und dann hätten
wir Ruhe und Frieden und wieder billiges
Gas den sei gesagt Putin würde sich
dadurch ermutigt fühlen
vorzuchtschreiten er würde Georgien er
würde Moldau er würde über kurz oder
lang auch die Frage der Landverbindung
in die Region Kaliningrad stellen und
wir würden über kurz oder lang als
Deutschland als Europa als NATO in einen
Konflikt mit Russland hineingeraten den
wir Gott sei jetzt mit der ukrainischen
Unterstützung und mit der Tapferkeit der
Ukrainer vielleicht abwenden können
insofern alle diejenigen die glauben wir
könnten durch Kompromiss mit putinen uns
die Sache ein Stück vom Hals halten den
sei gesagt das ist ein Trugschluss und
deswegen ist es nicht nur
moralischgerechtfertigt dass wir den
massiv unterstützen sondern das ist auch
eine ganz pragmatische ganz eigennützige
Perspektive aus Deutschland das zu tun
weil die Ukrainer tatsächlich eben auch
unseren Kampf kämpfen
[Applaus]
jetzt haben wir am
Wochenende am Sonntag die Gelegenheit
gehabt mit dem ukrainischen
Premierminister zu sprechen ich fand
übrigens bemerkenswert dass der Kanzler
zwar eine Pressekonferenz mit dem
Vorsitzenden der palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde macht aber für den eine
gemeinsame Pressekonferenz mit dem
ukrainischen Premierminister keine Zeit
hat das finde ich ist ein schwerer
diplomatischer Fehler gewesen
aber wir haben mit ihm gesprochen und
der hat eben ganz klar gesagt er setzt
auf Waffen auch aus Deutschland ich
erlebe hier Widersprüche des
Regierungshandelns der Bundeskanzler
betont immer wieder
man wolle keine nationalen Alleingänge
machen ich suche immer nach diesen
angeblichen möglichen alleinngängen wir
haben jetzt vereinbart der Slowakei
Leopard Panzer zu liefern damit sie
Schützenpanzer in die Ukraine liefern
kann wo wäre denn dann der Alleingang
wenn wir auch die Schützenpanzer Marder
die bei der deutschen Industrie auf dem
Hof stehen direkt an die Ukraine liefern
das wäre doch ein gemeinsames Handeln
Schützenpanzer aus verschiedenen
europäischen Ländern an die Ukraine das
sind leider alles vorgeschobene
Argumente und wenn man das beleuchtet
dann merkt man halt dass Aussagen wir
werden in Kürze zu einem Ringtausch der
marderpanzer mit anderen Ländern kommen
so getroffen vom Bundeskanzler Anfang
Juli Anfang September ist immer noch
nichts geschehen das ist keine
verlässliche Basis und deswegen müssen
sie uns zugestehen als Opposition dass
wir misstrauisch sind dass wir immer
wieder diese kritischen Fragen stellen
und die Dinge auch betonen
und ich komme zum Schluss zum zweiten
Thema was mich schwer beschäftigt Mali
wir haben in Mali einen
Auslandseinsatz auf der Basis des
parlamentsbeteiligungsgesetzes durch den
Deutschen Bundestag genehmigt das Gesetz
sieht vor dass diese Einsatz jederzeit
vom Bundestag zurückgeholt werden kann
das setzt aber voraus dass der Deutsche
Bundestag auch darüber beraten und
befinden kann ob das denn vielleicht
notwendig ist und wenn wir dann eine
Sondersitzung des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses und des
Verteidigungsausschusses beantragen
vorletzte Woche mit der Bitte wir
möchten doch bitte über Mali reden
Klammer auf die Verteidigungsministerin
hier sitzt ja auch hat in der
mandatsdebatte gesagt wenn wir keine
Kampfhubschrauber zum Schutz hätten wäre
das ein völlig verändertes Format und
dann muss dann auch mit den
parlamentarien und Parlamentariern
intensiv diskutiert werden haben sie
gesagt und dann sagen wir wir wollen
eine Sondersitzung haben wo wir das
besprechen ob es Handlungsbedarf des
Bundestages gibt dann kriegen wir haben
gesagt nee das machen wir Mittwoch
Morgen in der haushaltswoche um sieben
wenn es keiner mehr merkt da erwarten
wir dass das
parlamentsbeteiligungsgesetz sowohl nach
Buchstaben als auch im Geister
eingehalten wird und dass der Deutsche
Bundestag nicht mit dem Hinweis auf
Sommerpause daran gehindert wird sich
seine Meinung zu bilden ob der Einsatz
läuft in diesem Sinne biete ich
konstruktive konstruktive Gespräche über
den Haushalt an in dem Sinne wie sie
gesagt haben haben Sie unsere
Unterstützung hoffen wir mal dass es so
kommt und in diesem Sinne weiter gute
Beratung der außenpolitische Sprecher
Jürgen hart hat hier fast stärker die
bundesverteidigungsministerin
angesprochen Christine Lambrecht die ja
auch hier auf der Regierungsbank sitzt
natürlich vieles in diesen Bereich ist
Querschnitt wenn es um den mali-einsatz
geht wenn es natürlich um die Ukraine
Hilfe auch im Waffenlieferungen geht
aber wir sind noch im Einzelplan
Auswärtiges Amt bzw die Aussprache
beginnt eigentlich jetzt so richtig mit
Gabriele Heinrich jetzt beispielsweise
als nächster Rednerin für die SPD
die aktuellen Jahre als Zeiten der
globalen Krisen bezeichnen Klimawandel
Pandemie Konflikte bis hin zu einem
Krieg mit weltweiten Auswirkungen diese
Krisen bestimmen die internationale
Politik und in diesen Zeiten kommt dem
Haushalt des Auswärtigen Amtes natürlich
eine ganz besondere Bedeutung zu
Deutschland ist ein geschätzter und
anerkannter Partner steht aber gerade
auch deshalb unter Beobachtung durch
unsere Partnerländer
der Haushalt des Auswärtigen Amtes ist
ein Kristallisationspunkt für die
internationalen Beziehungen und für
Deutschlands Verantwortung in der Welt
und das muss auch im Einzelplan 05
abgebildet werden
die Vereinten Nationen als Garant für
eine regelbasierte Weltordnung wollen
und müssen wir weiter stärken die UNO
ist die Plattform für zahlreiche
fortschrittliche Initiativen
im Bereich
unter Umständen einen Frieden
vorzubereiten aber auch das
Klimaabkommen müssen wir erfüllen das
ist absolut zentral und wir verfolgen
weiterhin den multilateralen Ansatz was
in der Krise nicht leichter geworden ist
wir nehmen jetzt mit Beobachterstatus an
den Konferenzen des
atomwaffenverbotsvertragsteil und wir
helfen mit Konflikte friedlich unter
Leitung der UNO beizulegen
sehr verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
neben dem völkerrechtswidrigen Angriff
Russlands auf die Ukraine gibt es eben
leider auch in vielen Teilen der Welt
Gewalt Zerstörung sinnloses
Blutvergießen das aktuelle
friedensgutachten spricht von 128
Konflikten hinzu kommen die Auswirkungen
des Klimawandels Dürre und Hunger und
die UN warnen aktuell zum Beispiel vor
einer unmittelbar bevorstehen humanitäre
Notlage in Somalia
deutsche Außenpolitik muss in vielen
Regionen die blanken notlindern und
dafür brauchen wir eine starke
humanitäre Hilfe
deswegen sind viele von uns auch nicht
so glücklich mit einigen Ansätzen im
Einzelplan 05 der Ansatz für humanitäre
Hilfe im Ausland ist zwar in den letzten
zehn Jahren massiv gestiegen und das war
richtig er hat aber trotzdem schon in
der Vergangenheit nicht gereicht die
Mittel für humanitäre Hilfe im Ausland
müssen Kriege und die Folgen des
Klimawandels unbedingt abbilden und
dafür werden wir uns in den
Haushaltsberatungen einsetzen
ähnliches gilt für die auswärtige Kultur
im Bildungspolitik bereits angesprochen
sie sollen mit einem Finanzvolumen von
knapp einer Milliarde Euro ausgestattet
werden und wir werden auch hier
versuchen den Haushaltsberatungen die
sogenannte Kultur Milliarde wieder zu
erreichen sie ist wichtig mit diesen
Geldern betreiben wir werteorientierte
Außenpolitik Kultur Bildung das Angebot
zur Vermittlung unserer Werte alles das
stärkt die zivilschutzgesellschaft in
unseren Partnerländern und es ist denke
ich eine Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit hier
genug Geld in die Hand zu nehmen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
möchte das friedensgutachten noch einmal
heranziehen und zwar gibt es ein ganzes
Kapitel über die feministische
Außenpolitik und das ist eine lohnende
Lektüre da steht zum Beispiel
zitieren mit Ihrer Erlaubnis
internationale Politik muss inklusiver
werden sie muss Standards entgegenwirken
die auf überlegenheitsdenken
patriarchalischen Strukturen und Normen
der Heterosexualität basieren deshalb
ist es auch richtig dass das Auswärtige
Amt in diesem Sinne arbeitet so wie es
richtig ist dass die
entwicklungsministerin das Thema
feministische Entwicklungspolitik
besetzt feministischer Außenpolitik und
feministischer
Entwicklungspolitik das sind zwei Seiten
einer Medaille
die Bedürfnisse von Mädchen und Frauen
müssen überall mitgedacht werden ihnen
stehen die sogenannten drei erst zu
gleiche Rechte gleiche Ressourcen und
gleiche Repräsentanz und Frauen
angemessen zu einzubinden das ist wie
wir wissen sehr schlau die Stellung der
Frau ist der beste Indikator für die
Friedfertigkeit eines Staates werden die
Perspektiven von Frauen und Mädchen
nicht berücksichtigt bleiben
Krisenprävention
Krisenbewältigung immer unzureichen und
die Ursachen von Konflikten werden
allenfalls symptomatisch bearbeitet wir
wollen aber an die Wurzeln
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch ein
paar Worte zur Königsdisziplin des
Auswärtigen Amtes der Diplomatie sie
haben es erwähnt und wir und ich kann
sagen für die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion wir
haben stets deutlich gemacht wir geben
der Diplomatie immer den Vorrang
dass wir jetzt mehr
überwachenlieferungen und über
entlastungspakete für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger diskutiert werden
müssen das liegt allein am russischen
Überfall auf die Ukraine
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen putin
ist aktuell
Null an Verhandlungen interessiert und
er war es auch nie Olaf Scholz hat es ja
wie viele andere versucht wir können im
Moment nur die Tür offen halten die VN
wo es geht unterstützen ob Putin der
einst hindurchgeht das steht in den
Sternen
wir haben entschlossen auf diesen
Angriff reagiert und das war richtig im
besten Falle bereiten Unterstützung für
die Ukraine und Sanktionen gegen
Russland der Diplomatie den Weg im
genannten friedensgutachten von 2022
steht das so ich darf noch mal zu dir
Sanktionen und militärische
Unterstützung für die Ukraine müssen dem
Zweck dienen Russland zu einem
verlässlichen Waffenstillstand und
langfristig zu einer Friedenslösung zu
bewegen die Völkerrechtsbruch und das
ist wichtig nicht belohnt
Deutschland ist ein verlässlicher
respektierter und geachteter Partner in
der Welt die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion wird
sich dafür einsetzen dass dem
Auswärtigen Amt sein für seine wichtige
Arbeit ausreichend Mittel zur Verfügung
stehen für Diplomatie und
Krisenprävention für humanitäre Hilfe
Abrüstung und Rüstungskontrolle sowie
auswärtige Kultur und Bildungspolitik
wenn wir Verantwortung in der Welt
übernehmen wollen wenn wir diese Rolle
wirklich ausfüllen wollen dann kostet
das Geld Geld dass wir jetzt einplanen
müssen vielen Dank
er sagt Gabriela Heinrich für die
SPD-Fraktion des stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende allerdings sind
derzeit bei den haushaltsplanen im
Einzelplan bei zum Beispiel humanitärer
Hilfe auch krisens Präventionen
Kürzungen geplant aber die Verhandlungen
gehen ja sozusagen in den nächsten
Monaten dann erst in den nächsten Wochen
dann erst los Michael espendiller jetzt
für die afd-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im Saal
und bei Youtube die First Lady der
Ukraine hat kürzlich in einem Interview
gesagt während ihr Pfennige zählt zählen
wir Opfer für alle hart arbeitenden
Menschen in diesem Land war das mal
wieder ein Schlag ins Gesicht und eine
enorme Beleidigung gerade im Angesicht
der Tatsache dass Deutschland sich nicht
nur finanziell in erheblichen Umfang in
der Ukraine engagiert sondern auch
Waffen geliefert hat womit wir uns
selbst in Gefahr gebracht haben eine
Gefahr die sich jetzt realisiert man
muss sich das mal ganz in Ruhe vor Augen
führen durch die Globalisierung ist
unsere gesamte weltwirtschaftlich eng
miteinander verflochten unser Leben
Standard basiert auf Produktions- und
Lieferketten die um den ganzen Globus
führen und obwohl die EU das ganz genau
weiß meinte man man könnte diplomatisch
auf dicke Hose machen fängt ein Öl
embargo Sanktion gegen Russland und
erklärte man wolle auch auf russisches
Gas verzichten und dann ist das Geschrei
auf einmal groß wenn tatsächlich kein
russisches Gas mehr kommt mit Verlaub
Werte Bundesregierung aber ganz genau
hatten Sie denn erwartet was passiert
verstehen Sie mich richtig ich halte den
Angriff der Russen auf die Ukraine nach
wie vor für Grund falsch aber die
Reaktion der Bundesregierung auf diese
Krise hat insgesamt mehr geschadet als
genutzt gute Außenpolitik zeichnet sich
dadurch aus dass man Realitäten
anerkennt und eine Politik macht die
diesen Realitäten Rechnung trägt
und der Auftrag dieser Regierung ist nun
mal Schaden vom deutschen Volk
abzuwenden und seinen Nutzen zu mehren
und jetzt schauen wir uns doch mal an ob
diese Regierung diesen Auftrag erfüllt
hat zu Beginn des ukraine-konflikts
wurde hier der Eindruck vermittelt als
sei das alles ganz schnell vorbei die
russische Armee habe eine veraltete
Technik keine Kampfmoral und die Ukraine
würde das alles eindeutig für sich
entscheiden ein halbes Jahr später
dauern die Auseinandersetzung weiter an
beide Seiten haben tausende
Soldatenleben zu beklagen in diesem
Krieg verlieren beide Seiten und er ist
durch keiner der beiden Seiten zu
gewinnen auch mit ihren
Wirtschaftssanktionen hat sich die
Bundesregierung massiv verkalkuliert die
Sanktionen haben Russland eben nicht in
die Knie gezwungen wie man sich das so
schon vorgestellt hatte ganz im
Gegenteil wir haben ihn hier
vorhergesagt dass die Sanktion der
deutschen Wirtschaft und diesem
landschaden würden und was ist passiert
der Euro ist auf dem tiefsten Stand seit
20 Jahren die Inflationsrate in
Deutschland ist offiziell bei 9 Prozent
und wir alle spüren sie jeden Tag
versuchen sie bei jedem Einkauf beim
Tanken um auf die Arbeit zu kommen und
beim Blick auf unsere astronomische und
Gas-
und die Unternehmen wissen das auch
nicht mehr und mehr Unternehmen
schließen weil sie aufgrund der hohen
Energiepreise nicht mehr produzieren
können und das sind traditionsträchtige
Betriebe im Mittelstand und auch
Großfirmen die jetzt Insolvenz anmelden
und was ist die Ursache dieser
Preissteigerung es ist die
Sanktionspolitik mit der eigenen
Sanktionspolitik hat die Bundesregierung
zur Verknappung von Rohstoffen
beigetragen und wir alle wissen trifft
ein knappes Angebot auf eine hohe
Nachfrage resultieren daraus steigende
Preise und das ist nicht nur so dass
sich Deutschland damit ins eigene Knie
geschossen hat nein Russland wird durch
diese Sanktionspolitik auch nicht wie
beabsichtigt finanziell geschwächt
sondern hat sogar noch höhere Einnahmen
als vorher der rubelkurs ist auf
siebenjahres Hoch Gazprom hat im ersten
Halbjahr 2022 50 Prozent mehr Gewinn
erwirtschaftet als im Gesamtjahr davor
nach eigenen Angaben umgerechnet
41,63 Milliarden Euro und auch das G7
Mitglied Japan hat seine Verträge mit
Russland mittlerweile verlängert aber
das ist nur die wir welche Seite der
Medaille viel größere Sorgen machen wir
uns um die Versorgungssicherheit wir
verbrauchen derzeit große Mengen an Gas
um in Deutschland Strom zu erzeugen den
wir mittlerweile nach Frankreich
Österreich und Italien exportieren die
Gefahr von Blackouts wächst und das wird
sogar so konkret dass die Investmentbank
JP Morgan jetzt sogar schon Pläne
erarbeitet hat ihre Mitarbeiter im Falle
von großflächigen Stromausfällen nach
London zu verlagern das funktioniert für
die deutsche Bevölkerung aber nicht wenn
es zu einem mehrtägigen Stromausfall
kommt dann wird man feststellen dass die
Versorgung mit Nahrungsmitteln ohne
Strom nicht läuft man wird feststellen
dass das Telefon nicht mehr funktioniert
und man im Ernstfall keine Krankenwagen
keine Feuerwehr und keine polizeirufen
kann und in diesem Zusammenhang geht es
dann nicht mehr nur um Pfennige wie Frau
silensky das hier so verächtlich
ausgedrückt hat sondern da geht es auch
bei uns um Menschenleben wenn wir in den
nächsten Wochen also über den Etat des
Außenministeriums verhandeln da muss uns
allen klar sein dass dieser Etat nicht
nur Ausgaben in Höhe von 6,4 Milliarden
Euro umfasst sondern dass die
Außenpolitik dieser Bundesregierung auch
astronomische Kostenrisiken in sämtliche
anderen Einzelplänen für die Länder und
kommunalhaushälte für unsere Bürger und
für unsere Unternehmen verursacht
die Bundesregierung hat sich
diplomatisch verzockt und wenn das nicht
in einer Katastrophe enden soll dann ist
jetzt die Zeit gekommen seinen stolze
runterzuschlucken und endlich wieder
Politik für die Bürger im eigenen Land
zu machen danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
das Wort hat der Kollege Alexander Graf
Lamsdorf für die FDP-Fraktion und erster
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der Mittwochnachmittag in der
haushaltswoche ist sozusagen die
internationale Stunde dieses Parlaments
die Haushalte des Auswärtigen Amtes des
Bundesministeriums wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung und des
Bundesverteidigungsministeriums werden
debattiert und es gibt uns eine
Gelegenheit einmal innezuhalten und zu
schauen wo stehen wir eigentlich als
Deutschland in der Welt wir haben ein
Koalitionsvertrag geschlossen es ist
noch nicht mal ein Jahr her man macht
sich das gar nicht klar mir kommt schon
viel länger vor bei all dem was so
passiert aber da sind ein paar Punkte
drin die für uns aus der Sicht meiner
Fraktion ganz besonders wichtig sind und
in denen wir jetzt gemeinsam arbeiten
ich will diese drei hier mal
exemplarisch nennen das ist einmal die
Erarbeitung einer nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie da sehe ich das
Auswärtige Amt enorm engagiert mit
Outfit zum ganzen Land und die
Grundlinien Sicherheit unserer Freiheit
die Sicherung des Friedens bei uns und
die Sicherheit unserer Lebensgrundlagen
sind ein wirklich guter Startpunkt für
eine starke nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie die im nächsten
Jahr dann bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz vorgestellt werden
soll das heute ist dass wir als FDP auch
gerne wollten und was wir jetzt auch
gemeinsam machen ist die Überprüfung
unserer bundeswehrmandate das Irak
Mandat wird gerade überprüft und bei
minusma sind wir in täglichen Austausch
zwischen den Ressorts zwischen den
Fraktionen mit den internationalen
Partnern ich will hier eines sagen
dieses Mandat ist nach Auffassung meiner
Fraktion enorm wichtig eine wirklich
enorm wichtige Tätigkeit die wir da auf
unserem Nachbarkontinent für die
Stabilität des Seil leisten ich würde
mir daher sehr wünschen dass wir bei der
Evaluierung zum Ergebnis kommen dass wir
unser Engagement eher ausweiten als es
zu reduzieren und der dritte Punkt
und der dritte Punkt meine Damen und
Herren das ist die Überprüfung der
Wirksamkeit der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit aber das wird
beim Einzelplan 23 dann im Einzelnen zu
besprechen sein am 24 februar ist aber
alles das was wir uns so vorgenommen
hatten ruhig zu bearbeiten und
abzuarbeiten natürlich vollkommen über
den Haufen geworfen worden die
Ministerin hat hier alles gesagt zur
Situation zur Politik der Bundesrepublik
im Hinblick auf die Ukraine die
sogenannte Zeitenwende Rede des
Bundeskanzlers war enorm wichtig ich
möchte hier einmal unterstreichen dass
es mich stolz macht dass wir in dieser
kritischen Stunde als Parlament in die
demokratischen Fraktionen zusammenstehen
konnten dass hier die Opposition genau
das getan hat was jürgen hat gesagt hat
konstruktiv daran mitgearbeitet dass wir
eine solide gemeinsame deutsche
Außenpolitik in so einer schweren Krise
entwerfen können dafür ganz herzlichen
Dank
meine Damen und Herren
einige das muss man der Fairness halber
sagen haben die zeitenwände allerdings
schon vorher kommen sehen die Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz hat im Jahr 2020
bereits ein Bericht veröffentlicht mit
dem Titel Zeitenwende weil die Welt
vorher schon ungemütlicher härter ja
gefährlicher wurde Freedom House
schreibt uns ein Stammbuch der seit 15
16 17 Jahren die Zahl der freien Länder
zurück in die Zahl der Autokratien
ansteigt die Frage ist ist das eine
Gesetzmäßigkeit es ist vorbei mit der
Ausbreitung von Demokratie und
Rechtsstaat ich glaube das können wir
nicht so hinnehmen wir müssen auf Werte
setzen wir müssen aus Völkerrecht setzen
wir müssen noch Multilateralismus setzen
in dem Zusammenhang übrigens kommt
wieder minusma das ist ein starker
Beitrag den Deutschland auch zu den
Vereinten Nationen leitet in der
Europäischen Union haben wir in mehreren
Mitgliedstaaten
schwere Probleme mit der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit ich erwähne Ungarn
ich erwähne Polen aber auch Länder wie
Slowenien Malta und Bulgarien machen uns
Sorgen wenn wir auf die Medienlandschaft
auf die Rechtsstaatlichkeit auf die
akademische Freiheit schauen auch hier
ist es vorbei mit der ever closer Union
auch das sollten und können wir nicht
hinnehmen wir müssen dagegenhalten mit
dem starken rechtsstaatsmechanismus mit
der Einführung von Mehrheitsentscheidung
mit Europa politischem Engagement und
die Globalisierung die Wirtschaft war
ehrlich gesagt schon vor dem Ukraine
Krieg durch diese wirklich
borniert harte zero-covit Politik Chinas
durch die disruptionen in den
Lieferketten schwer gestört hinzu kamen
auch noch Protektionismus
protektionistische Tendenzen leider
haben wir sie gerade wieder in Amerika
gesehen mit dem Beschluss E-Autos nur
noch dann zu fördern wenn sie komplett
in Amerika hergestellt sind nein meine
Damen und Herren wir dürfen uns den
Protektionismus nicht ergeben wir müssen
hier ceter ratifizieren wir sollten über
Merkur möglichst schnell reden und wir
müssen weitere Handelsabkommen schließen
wir die Globalisierung ist die Grundlage
des Wohlstands unseres Landes meine
Damen und Herren
habe ich gerade gesagt ceta muss
ratifiziert werden unsere Freiheit
unsere Sicherheit und unser Wohlstand
hängen von vielen ab was wir hier in
Deutschland selber tun aber sie hängen
auch von der Welt um uns herum ab und
davon wie wir sie gestalten arbeiten wir
gemeinsam daran die Welt so zu gestalten
dass bei uns Frieden Sicherheit und
Wohlstand gewährleistet bleiben
herzlichen Dank
Alexander Graf lambsdorf für die AFD FDP
war das er hat es auch angesprochen
unter anderem der
minusma-einsatz ist es ja die UN-Mission
in Mali wo die Bundeswehr auch beteiligt
ist und die Bundeswehr hat gerade jetzt
gestern ihre Operation in Mali im Rahmen
dieser UN-Mission wieder aufgenommen
nämlich da gab es ja wegen eines Streits
um den kontingentwechsel und
überflugsrechte mit der malischen
Militärregierung im Rahmen dieses blauen
auswärtseinsatzes gab es Konflikte
deswegen wurde das ausgesetzt und im
Moment wird darauf darüber gerungen wie
sieht es mit der Sicherheit der
deutschen Soldatinnen und Soldaten aus
und soll dieser Einsatz von Seiten
Deutschlands auch von der Bundeswehr
weitergeführt werden Gregor wie sie
jetzt für die Linke Verheerungen die es
während des Kalten Krieges gab die
Stabilität größer war als heute
allein Russland die Schuld dafür zu
geben ist falsch gerade auch der Westen
hat zur b-stabilisierung beigetragen
trotzdem sind wir uns einig dass der
völkerrechtswidrige Krieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine schafft verurteilt
werden muss
wie soll der Krieg beendet werden es
geht nur über einen Kompromiss zwischen
der Ukraine und Russland und dafür muss
diplomatisch vermittelt werden unsere
Außenpolitik versagt diesbezüglich
vollständig der Vermittler zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine ist die Türkei
die als NATO-Mitglied gerade
völkerrechtsführende Kriege gegen Syrien
und den Irak führt und außerdem noch
Griechenland bedroht wäre die
vermittlungsrolle nicht eigentlich eine
Aufgabe des Bundeskanzlers Scholz und
des französischen Präsidenten macron und
eben nicht des Präsidenten Erdogan sie
wissen dass ich aus historischen Gründen
dagegen bin dass Deutschland ein kriegen
verdient und Waffen exportiert aber
unabhängig davon kann man sich doch
nicht nur obwattenlieferungen
konzentrieren und auf eine diplomatische
Lösung verzichten
ich habe immer Sanktionen gegen die
russische Führung und gegen die
russischen Oligarchen unterstützt aber
ich verstehe diese Aktion gegen die
russische Bevölkerung nicht sie hat den
Krieg nicht beschlossen warum soll sie
darunter leiden warum ist es überhaupt
Ziel unserer Regierung dass die
russische Bevölkerung leidet sollte der
über Hoffnung dahinter stecken dass sich
die Bevölkerung dann gegen Putin stellt
muss ich Ihnen sagen dass die Medienwelt
in Russland von Putin und nicht von uns
bestimmt wird er wird wohl eher dafür
sorgen dass eine Stimmung gegen uns
entsteht von Anfang an habe ich gefragt
welche Gegenmaßnahmen gegen uns und
gegen andere von Putin eingeleitet
werden können ich habe darauf
hingewiesen dass ein Drittel des
weltweiten getreideexports aus Russland
und der Ukraine kommt und das doch die
Gefahr besteht dass dies beeinträchtigt
wird und tatsächlich wurde es ja
beeinträchtigt bis ein Kompromiss über
den Generalsekretär der UNO gut Harris
und eben Präsident erreicht wurde nicht
etwa über uns und ich habe darauf
hingewiesen dass Russland wenn es andere
Kunden vererdöl und Erdgas finden sollte
den Hahn zu uns auch zudrehen kann nun
sagen die Besserverdienenden dass man
das in Kauf nehmen muss wir haben einen
Preis zu bezahlen das stimmt das ist für
Bundestagsabgeordnete zum Beispiel auch
kein Problem aber es gibt viele die sich
das beim besten Willen nicht leisten
können und was sie da an Hilfe anbieten
ist unzureichend und Flickschusterei sie
vergessen viele Gruppen zum Beispiel die
Menschen in privater Insolvenz wo jede
zusätzliche Betrag an den
Insolvenzverwalter geht sie vergessen
die Freiberuflerinnen und Freiberufler
darunter sehr viele Künstlerinnen und
Künstler die sich das beim besten Willen
nicht leisten können sie vergessen auch
die solo-selbstständigen und die kleinen
und mittleren Unternehmen bisher haben
Rentnerinnen und Rentner noch gar nichts
bekommen das soll nun durch einen der
Betrag geändert werden aber der reicht
nicht hin und her außerdem vergessen Sie
die große Gruppe der Normalverdienenden
die sich die Inflation die
Preissteigerung bei Lebensmitteln und
Energie ebenfalls nicht leisten kann
deshalb wäre es wichtig über bestimmte
Sanktionen neue nachzudenken um
andererseits die Energieversorgung
unserer Bevölkerung in vollem Umfang zu
sichern ferner fehlt mir jede
Perspektive ihrer Politik wie soll
eigentlich eine neue Friedensordnung
weltweit und in Europa aussehen sie
müssen immer bedenken dass es ohne und
gegen Russland eine solche nicht geben
kann wenigstens Vorschläge der Regierung
Ideen müsste man erleben aber sie fehlen
sie Frau Außenministerin wollten eine
Außenpolitik zur Vermeidung des
Klimawandels betreiben was ohne und
gegen Russland auch nicht geht es tut
mir leid aber ich habe insgesamt den
Eindruck dass die Regierung überfordert
ist
wir erleben eine Konkurrenz zwischen den
USA China und Russland wir Europäerinnen
und Europäer sind daran interessiert
nicht unter dieser Konkurrenz zu leiden
das wird aber in der Außenpolitik nicht
deutlich und ich erinnere daran dass die
Mehrheit der Staaten nicht demokratisch
strukturiert ist es gibt das berühmte
Bündnis bricks bestehend aus Brasilien
Russland Indien China und Südafrika
diese Staaten zusammen machen deutlich
mehr als die Hälfte der Menschheit aus
und nun wird auch noch die Konkurrenz
zwischen den USA und China dramatisch
zugespitzt wir sind keine Weltmacht aber
können und müssen einen Beitrag leisten
die Demokratie und Stabilität in unserem
Land und in der EU zu erhalten und das
ganze darf nicht aus dem Ruder laufen
damit wir nicht in den Dritten Weltkrieg
geraten dazu muss die Diplomatie um
Unterschied zu jeder Kriegspolitik
weltweit deutlich gestärkt werden auch
durch unsere Bundesregierung
war das der außenpolitische Sprecher der
Linksfraktion ja was die Sanktionen
gegen Russland anbelangt
da wird Anna-Lena bärburg und die
Bundesregierung für eine andere Liebe
Deutschland
das Paket mit EU-Sanktionen gegen
Russland dazu hat beispielsweise an der
Leder baerbock in der vergangenen Woche
am Rande eines
eu-außenministertreffens Vorschläge
gemacht
ich finde es sehr interessant dass sie
nachdem unsere Außenministerin hier
mehrere Minuten lang unsere
diplomatischen Bemühungen erklärt sagen
dass sie nicht verstehen was die
diplomatischen Wege sind die diese
Regierung geht ich empfehle Ihnen da
einfach das nächste Mal vielleicht ein
bisschen aufmerksamer zuzuhören und man
sie gerne die Regierung mehr soziales zu
märz für soziale Entlastung zu tun aber
bitte hören Sie auf das gegen das Leid
der Menschen der Ukraine auszuspielen
wir haben gerade schon darüber
gesprochen der russische Angriffskrieg
hat schwere Auswirkungen auf die Energie
und Ernährungssicherheit in der ganzen
Welt die Folgen des Krieges aber auch
der sich verschärfenden Klimakrise
destabilisieren unsere regelbasierte
Ordnung und sie lassen deshalb auch
gefährliche Lehrstellen für
demokratiefreibe in dieser Zeit brauchen
wir ein handlungsfähigen Staat und eine
glaubwürdige und verlässliche Politik
gegenüber unseren internationalen
Partnern die Finanzierungslücken der
Bundeswehr haben wir jetzt geschlossen
weil Diplomatie und
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit müssen wir
diese zeitenwände noch schaffen
der vorliegende Etat des Auswärtigen
Amtes liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
möchte ich so ehrlich sagen wird diesem
Anspruch noch nicht gerecht wegen der
fehlenden Handlungsspielräume gibt es
darin zum Beispiel Kürzungen bei der
humanitären Hilfe um 500 Millionen und
bei der auswärtigen Kultur-
lieber Otto ich sag ja einfach wir haben
da noch ein bisschen Arbeit vor uns aber
humanitäre Hilfe und auswärtige
Kulturpolitik für mich einfach Geschenke
an andere Länder diese Gelder sorgen für
ein Mindestmaß an Menschlichkeit nach
Naturkatastrophen wie etwa bei den
schrecklichen Überflutungen Pakistan
oder Hungerkrisen die derzeit in Somalia
und sie unterstützen die
Zivilbevölkerung zum Beispiel in der
Ukraine die durch die russische
Artillerie momentan ihr Hab und Gut
verliert und sie unterstützen eben auch
kritischen Journalismus und die
demokratische Zivilgesellschaft das ist
nicht einfach ein nice to have das ist
unverzichtbar diese Gelder die erfüllen
einen humanistischen Zweck aber sie
machen eben auch die Bundesrepublik zu
einem verlässlichen Partner in der Welt
wir müssen einen Verlust an
Glaubwürdigkeit und Handlungsfähigkeit
unserer internationalen Politik in
dieser großen Krise vermeiden jetzt an
den falschen Stellen zu sparen bedeutet
eine gefährliche Lücke für
imperialistische und menschenverachtende
Politik von Putin g und Co weiter zu
öffnen und wir sehen jetzt schon einen
massiven Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust in
Afrika Lateinamerika und in Südostasien
durch humanitäre Hilfe aber und kluge
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen und eine Stärkung
der diplomatischen Beziehungen auch im
Bildungs- und Kulturbereich können wir
diesen Trend umdrehen und eine
Verlässlichkeit unter Beweis stellen
denn Werte verteidigt man dann am besten
indem man sie selbst vorlebt
glaubwürdigkeit ist das allerbeste
Mittel gegen die Autokraten in dieser
Welt liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es
ist doch alle absehbar für uns auch dass
wir 2023 weiterhin eine starke
Außenpolitik benötigen um eben
handlungsfähig in diesen Zeiten zu sein
für diese wichtige Arbeit unsere
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock gegen
das großmachtgehabe von Autokraten in
dieser Welt brauchen wir mehr
Handlungsspielräume wir werden daher im
Parlament sicherlich noch viele Debatten
darüber führen und auch in den kommenden
Wochenenddienst Entwurf weiterarbeiten
ich freue mich auf die Zusammenarbeit
mit dem Auswärtigen Amt aber auch mit
Ihnen und Euch liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen vielen Dank er sagt Jamila
Schäfer für die Grünen mehrfach schon
angesprochen die Kürzungen die im
Entwurf stehen für die humanitäre Hilfe
auch für kulturelle Beziehungen und zum
Ausland also da gibt es auch von den
Abgeordneten der ampelfraktion ein
nachbesserungswünsche wir haben noch mal
was die cdu/csu dazu zu sagen hat Gunter
Kriechbaum frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ich habe mir
heute morgen notiert bei der Rede des
Bundeskanzlers was dieser zum Thema
Europa gesagt hat
und das ist das Ergebnis das ist das
Ergebnis er hat kein einziges Mal etwas
zu Europa gesagt und das genau ist das
Problem das ist das Problem liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegin wir tun in diesen
Tagen so als wären wir auf dieser Welt
allein im europäischen Ausland ist man
entsetzt über uns in Zeiten der größten
Energiekrise auf unserem Kontinent geht
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland geht
diese Bundesregierung her und möchte 30
im Betrieb befindliche AKWs vom Netz
nehmen das ist die Wahrheit und es geht
weiter es geht weiter dass man zwei
jetzt dieser AKWs noch weiter betreiben
möchte die aber dann keinen Strom
produzieren dürfen das ist
betriebswirtschaftlicher Irrsinn meine
Damen und Herren das macht doch keiner
mit hier in Deutschland und sorgen dann
noch dafür dass weil Angebot und
Nachfrage eben den Preis regeln dass ich
Strom weiter verknappt teurer wird und
dann unsere europäischen Partner im
Ausland diesen teuren Strom auch
einkaufen müssen wir haben auch hier
eine europäische Solidarität wir müssen
dafür sorgen in Zeiten einer
Angebotsknappheit dass wir unsere
Beitrag liefern alles was möglich ist
damit auch hier der Preis sich nicht
weiter verteuert und wir auch für unsere
Wirtschaft sichere Perspektiven haben
aber
es geht auch noch weiter wir verlassen
uns darauf dass wir in Frankreich dann
Atomstrom einkaufen können in Frankreich
sind viele AKWs noch nicht unter
Volllast wieder am Netz weil aufgrund
der Wartungszyklen die hätten
eingehalten werden müssen noch in
Ausfluss der corona-pandemie nicht unter
früheren Bedingungen produziert werden
können auch da lügen wir uns liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in die Tasche
wenn wir den Atomstrom hier nicht
produzieren wollen aber dann im Ausland
einkaufen das macht wenig Sinn ich weiß
im übrigen dass das in Teilen der
Bundesregierung blockiert wird und auch
längst nicht in allen Teilen so gesehen
wird was wir allerdings auch nicht aus
dem Blick heraus verlieren dürfen ist
die ukrainische Stromproduktion
und hier nehme ich ganz speziell
natürlich das AKW in subway-sacha das
heißt hier wird auch Strom produziert
wir hatten am letzten Sonntag den
Premierminister aus der Ukraine zum
Gespräch hier in Berlin von den 6 Blocks
sind zwei in der Vergangenheit dafür
verantwortlich gewesen die Ukraine mit
Strom zu versorgen der Strom der übrigen
4 Blocks ging in den Export wir wissen
wie gefährlich im Augenblick die
Situation ist deswegen bin auch ich
persönlich dankbar ich denke wir alle
dankbar dass zurzeit ein Team der eio
vor Ort ist in einer sehr gefährlichen
in einer sehr brenzlichen Situation um
sich dort einen Überblick zu verschaffen
und womöglich auch zu retten was zu
retten ist
deswegen dieser Mut der dortigen
Delegation verdient unseren Dank aber es
offenbart eben auch dass hier Putin die
Energie als Waffe einsetzt auch
gegenüber dem Westen deswegen finde ich
es schon irritieren wenn hier stimmen
sich erheben inmitten des Parlaments
doch bitte Nord Stream 2 in Betrieb zu
nehmen weil ja dann alle Probleme gelöst
wären vielleicht hat man da noch nicht
überall begriffen das Putin gedenkt die
das Gas insgesamt zu sanktionieren und
nordstream 2 an der Stelle überhaupt
nichts ausrichten würde
Kanzler Scholz hat aber dafür einiges
zum Thema Europa in Prag gesagt bei
seiner Prager Rede und erschreckend war
nicht die Rede an sich sondern
erschreckend war die Resonanz darauf es
wurde in Europa darüber in manchen
Tageszeitungen berichtet aber so gut wie
nicht kommentiert und schon gar nicht
von den dortigen Regierungen rezip das
heißt es wird dann von deutscher Seite
zu Europa vorgetragen und niemanden
interessiert es mehr das zur deutschen
Führungsrolle in Europa er hat gesagt um
das gleich aufzugreifen etwas zur
Sicherheitspolitik wir brauchen in
Zukunft ein gemeinsames Luftabwehrsystem
in Europa das hat
Kolleg schon vor Monaten hier im
Deutschen Bundestag gesagt dass wir
etwas wie den eierndom brauchen insoweit
freuen wir uns wenn jetzt diese Ideen
zeigt uns der Bundesregierung und zeigt
uns von Olaf Scholz aufgegriffen werden
zum Thema Mehrheitsprinzip das ist alles
schön und gut was auch da vorgetragen
wurde oder meinetwegen auch zur Zahl der
Kommissare aber Scholz bleibt die
Antwort schuldig wie er überhaupt dahin
gelangen will das ist doch das Problem
an sich und auch dazu war überhaupt
nichts vorgetragen insoweit war die Rede
dann im Ergebnis enttäuschend vielleicht
auch noch mal ein Wort zur zeitenwender
zur vielzitierten Zeitenwende die
zeitenwände war wenn wir uns alle hier
ehrlich machen nicht der 24 Februar 2022
die Zeitenwende war der 18 märz 2014
hier wurde die Krim einverleiht das war
die faktische Annektion und aus Sicht
Russlands die Jura Annektion der kriegt
und deswegen wir hätten hier schon
früher reagieren müssen das gehört zu
unserer Ehrlichkeit wenn wir uns ehrlich
machen hier dazu und deswegen müssen wir
auch sorgsamer hinschauen auf der Welt
Griechenland Türkei was sich in diesen
Tagen tut Chinas Afrika am Engagement in
Afrika der heutige Tag wäre für Kanzler
Scholz eine perfekte Gelegenheit gewesen
hier Position zu beziehen und manches
klar zu stellen eine verpasste Chance
ein verpasster Tag herzlichen Dank ja
das kritisiert hier Gunther Kriechbaum
für die CDU-Fraktion er hat es
angesprochen nur noch mal zum
Hintergrund Ende August hatte Olaf
Scholz an der Prager Karls-Universität
eine Rede zu den Folgen der zeitenwände
gehalten und plädierte dort für eine
unabhängigere Europäische Union Frank
Schwabe jetzt für die SPD
verehrte Damen und Herren Herr
Kriechbaum vielleicht sollten sich noch
mal ihr
für das Protokoll sich das noch mal
angucken was sie gerade erzählt haben
sie haben ja ein bisschen die Ströme
dargestellt wie sich der Strom so
verteilt die Wahrheit ist ja das in der
Regel wir aus Deutschland Strom nach
Frankreich exportieren und der
Bundeskanzler ist heute morgen schon mal
gesagt während wir Ihren atompolitischen
Vorstellungen gefolgt dann wären wir
nicht da wo wir heute sind auch nicht
beim Ausbau der neubaren Energien und
wenn in der Tat in der
energiepolitischen Sackgasse und
deswegen empfehle ich auch an der Stelle
nicht ihren Vorstellungen zu folgen
[Applaus]
und finanziell die Spielräume in diesem
Bundeshaushalt entsprechend eng sind und
deswegen wird es eine große
Herausforderung und ich habe ja von fast
allen nicht alle haben es erwähnt aber
von fast allen hier gehört dass das was
im auswärtigen Etat ist aber auch im
Entwicklungsbereich zu wenig ist und
deswegen wird es an uns allen sein bis
zum November dafür zu sorgen dass wir
den Herausforderungen da jedenfalls
stärker gerecht werden das wird eine
harte Arbeit die auf uns zukommt das was
die Welt ist hat glaube ich das
beschrieben was heute morgen an würdiger
Verabschiedung von Michael Gorbatschow
durch die Bundestagspräsidentin
vorgenommen wurde und wenn man das
vergleicht eben mit der Realität von
Wladimir Putin im Jahr 20 20 dann
beschreibt ist das eigentlich was wir an
Hoffnung hatten in den letzten 30 Jahren
was wir auch erreicht haben zum Beispiel
beim Aufbau des internationalen
Strafgerichtshofes des Jugoslawien
Tribunals im Bereich der Abrüstung was
aber auch in den letzten Jahren zunichte
gemacht wurde und was eben auch gerade
aktuell politisch nicht mehr möglich ist
diese Regierung hat sich vorgenommen den
Multilateralismus zu stärken
Menschenrechte in den Mittelpunkt zu
stellen die Schwachen zu stärken durch
eine feministische Außen- und
Entwicklungspolitik
geflüchteten Schutz zu stärken und
Krisenprävention humanitäre Hilfe und
auswärtige Kultur und Bildungspolitik zu
stärken so steht das jedenfalls im
Koalitionsvertrag aber alles das Gerät
eben zurzeit unter Druck durch eine
Realität an der brutalen Machtpolitik
wie wir sie eben durch Russlands
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine sehen
durch das was China immer mehr tut und
andere Länder aber eben auch und
gleichzeitig haben wir eben geringere
Spielräume im Bundeshaushalt und dennoch
deutsche Außenpolitik die jedenfalls
Menschenrechte auch in der Mittelpunkt
stellen will muss Klartext reden mit
anderen Ländern muss bilateral Klartext
reden und muss das auch durchhalten auch
in diesen aktuellen Zeiten auch bei
Regierungskonsultationen die stattfinden
ich will das Beispiel Indien nennen ein
Land mit dem wir eine gute Partnerschaft
haben wollen und haben müssen in der
Klimapolitik in der Wirtschaftspolitik
bei der Frage des Multilateralismus wo
es aber eben auch hochproblematische
Entwicklung gibt durch einen um sich
greifenden Internationalismus
Einschränkung von Religionsfreiheit und
eben auch durch die Einschränkung von
Menschenrechts und nicht
Regierungsorganisationen und dennoch
müssen wir Klartext reden auch wenn wir
Indien für einen Multilateralismus für
unsere multilaterale Politik brauchen
und wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
Außenpolitik und Entwicklungspolitik
ausreichend ausgestattet ist und ich
will es noch mal sagen im
Koalitionsvertrag steht dass wir ein
aufwuchs haben wollen der Mittel wenn
dann im militärischen Bereich ein
aufwuchs stattfindet der notwendig ist
von eins zu eins im Bereich der
Außenpolitik und der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit wir haben
einen Jahrzehnt gehabt wenn man sich die
Zahlen anguckt einer sehr positiven
Entwicklung wir sind in Richtung 0,7
Prozent marschiert im Bereich der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit wir haben im
Bereich der humanitären Hilfe ein
aufwuchs gehabt von 350 Millionen auf
2,7 Milliarden wir haben die auswärtige
Kultur- und Bildungspolitik gestärkt wir
haben mehr Mittel eingesetzt für den
internationalen Klimaschutz aber summa
summarum würde ich mal so sagen
roundabout fehlen jetzt zwei oder drei
Milliarden in diesem Bundeshaushalt und
ich sage es nochmal wenn wir den
internationalen Anforderungen gerecht
werden wollen in dieser Zeit wenn wir
die Balance halten wollen zwischen dem
was für militärisch tun müssen und dem
was aber unser Anspruch eben auch im
zivilen Bereich der Krisenprävention und
der Krisenhilfe ist dann ist noch viel
Arbeit zu tun bis zum November
ich will
betonen dass wir im Bereich des
Bundeshaushalts im Bereich der
Menschenrechtspolitik im Bereich des
Ausbaus der menschenrechtsarchitektur
viel erreichen wir haben die Botschaften
besser ausgestattet dass sie
Menschenrechtsthemen stärker adressieren
können wir haben uns vorgenommen die
Beauftragte für Menschenrecht und
humanitäre Hilfe in ihrem Amt zu stärken
und wir sind dabei den Multilateralismus
auch finanziell zu unterstützen und mein
Paradebeispiel ist immer der Europarat
weil es eben auch eine große
Herausforderung ist wenn wir die Welt
beschreiben wie schwierig sie ist in den
Herausforderungen von Demokratie
Menschenrechte und Rechtsstaatlichkeit
dann ist der Kern des Ganzen am Ende
doch dieses Europa und wir müssen alles
tun dieses Europa dann auch als Kern
dieser Werte zu erhalten das wird
schwierig genug wir haben Russland
rausgeworfen aus dem Europarat zu Recht
wir haben Länder dabei wie Ungarn Polen
wie die Türkei wie Aserbaidschan aber
leider auch Länder wie Dänemark die
Großbritannien hoffentlich nicht eine
neue Regierung in Italien die ist mit
bestimmten Dingen des
Menschenrechtsschutzes das Respektes der
Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention
auch nicht so ernst nimmt ich sehe große
Probleme auf uns ich lebt ja ja ja ja
alles das ich sehe große Probleme auf
uns zukommen was den Respekt des
europäischen Gerichtshaus für
Menschenrechte angeht und dessen Urteile
und deswegen sage ich umso mehr muss das
im Zentrum auch der deutschen
Außenpolitik stellen und das wird auch
deutlich in diesem Haushalt durch eine
Stärkung der Mittel für den Europarat
das finde ich gut und ich finde das
verdient den Respekt und die
Unterstützung auch das gesamten Hauses
vielen Dank
Frank Schwabe für die SPD-Fraktion
zu diesem Einzelplan des Auswärtigen
Amtes Bericht jetzt für die afd-fraktion
Peter bist
[Applaus]
ja hallo Frau Bär Box schön dass Sie da
sind nach dem was ihr letzte Woche in
Prag von sich gegeben haben hätten wir
gedacht sie sitzen in Parlament heute
aber im Ernst im Ernst Frau Werbung dass
sie hier noch auf dem ministersessel
selbst die unterbrechen Herr bistronen
sie wollen sich sicherlich korrigieren
was den Anfang ihrer Rede betrifft sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und liebe Kollegen
dass die Frau Außenministerin hier noch
auf dem
ministersitzer sitzt nachdem sie die
deutschen Wähler letzte Woche beleidigt
hat nachdem sie ihr Amtseid mit Füßen
getreten hat das ist in meinen Augen ein
Skandal
aber zu ihrer Rede Frau Werbung sie
haben gesagt sie wollen in der Ukraine
Menschen leben retten sie haben das
mehrmals wiederholt und wir machen sie
das in den letzten sechs Monaten mit
Sanktionen gegen Russland und mit
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
helfen
Menschenleben retten nein nein sie
verlängern damit lediglich den Krieg sie
verlängern das Leid der Frauen und
Mädchen die sie erwähnt haben die auf
ihre Jungs warten die da in dem Krieg
verheizt werden das machen sie ihre alte
und die einzigen den sie helfen auf
Kosten der deutschen Steuerzahler und
Wähler sind die US-Amerikaner auf der
einen Seite verhelfen Sie den
militärisch industriellem Komplex nach
vier Jahren ohne Kriege unter Präsident
Donald Trump nach vier Jahren
Durststrecke zu den lang ersehnten
Milliarden Aufträgen und auf der anderen
Seite verhelfen Sie den Falten in
Washington ihr langfristiges Ziel zu
erreichen nämlich ein Spalt zwischen uns
auf der einen Seite Europa und
Deutschland auf der einen Seite und
Russland auf der anderen Seite zu
treiben und uns beide damit zu schwächen
[Applaus]
und Sanktionen Sanktionen haben die
Sanktionen Russland gesteckt nein haben
sie nicht sie haben sie nicht vom Krieg
abgehalten und sie haben das Gegenteil
bewirkt durch das ihr embargo sind die
Öl- und Gaspreise gestiegen russland hat
Rekordgewinne vermeldet und die
russische Wirtschaft verzeichnet
Wachstumsraten wie schon seit langem
nicht mehr und das ist keine
putinpropaganda das sagen Experten von
JP Morgan und vom Blumberg liebe Freunde
aus den USA
[Applaus]
geschadet haben die Sanktionen sehr wohl
es geschadet haben sie Deutschland
unseren Bürgern wir hier in Deutschland
müssen zwei Euro 40 Liter Sprit Zahlen
unsere Gas und Stromrechnung gehen durch
die Decke unsere Firmen gehen pleite so
wie gestern gerade herkle eine Firma mit
100-jährige Tradition sie vernichten
Arbeitsplätze sie vernichten einen von
Generationen erarbeiteten Wohlstand in
Deutschland
und mir egal liebe Kollegen wie sie das
hier nachher noch mal in ihren Reden die
Wahrheit verdrehen die Bürger erleben
die Realität tagtäglich die wissen was
passiert die kennen die Wahrheit 22
Prozent der Bürger wollen keine weiteren
Waffenlieferungen
77% wollen Friedensverhandlungen steigt
weitere Kriegstreiberei und 87 Prozent
87 Prozent wollen Gespräche mit Russland
statt einseitigen Bashing und Sanktionen
und jetzt
machen sie genau das Gegenteil von dem
was die Bürger wollen und verlangen von
uns auch noch sechs Milliarden für diese
Politik warum sollten wir dem zustimmen
warum warum sollten wir denn zustimmen
wir von der AFD sind hier um die
deutschen Wähler zu vertreten die sie so
verachten wir sind hier um die Menschen
vor ihnen zu schützen deswegen bekommen
Sie von uns für ihre menschenverachtende
Politik keinen Cent der Leben lehnen
ihren Antrag ab
[Applaus]
für die FDP-Fraktion hat nun die
Kollegin Renate
ist die Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe des
Bundestages
sehr geehrte Frau Bundestags Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren ich bin mir sicher Frau
bundesaußenministerin die deutsche
Bevölkerung muss nicht vor ihnen
geschützt werden die Ampel
die Ampel legt einen Haushalt vor der
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Deutschland entlastet einen Haushalt der
aber auch die Schwachen in der Welt
nicht vergessen die Anzahl der
Krisenherde weltweit nimmt zu wir helfen
Menschen in Not wo wir nur können in der
Ukraine in Somalia in Afghanistan und
vielen anderen Ländern dieser Welt in
Afghanistan müssen Mädchen wie Mariam
Hamidi geheime Mädchenschulen besuchen
wenn sie lesen und schreiben lernen
wollen das drakonische Taliban regime
verwehrt Frauen und Mädchen sämtliche
Rechte dabei dürfen wir nicht tatenlos
zuschauen
humanitäre Hilfe muss an Menschenrechte
geknüpft werden für uns Freie Demokraten
sind Menschenrechte nicht verhandelbar
wir helfen gerne aber wir müssen auch
fordern Geld für Frauenrechte Geld für
den Frieden Geld für Freiheit Geld für
Menschenrechte dabei dürfen wir keine
parallelsysteme finanzieren es ist die
Aufgabe von Regierungen für Bildung
Gesundheit und Nahrungsmittel der
eigenen Bevölkerung zu sorgen diese
Aufgaben sollten wir nicht dauerhaft für
Sie übernehmen
humanitäre Hilfe muss Leid lindern darf
aber kein Dauerzustand sein wir wollen
Krisen rasch beenden und wenn möglich
verhindern das sollte der Zentrale
Anspruch der humanitäre Hilfe
Deutschlands sein deutschland ist der
zweitgrößte Geber
deutschland ist der zweitgrößte Geber
von humanitären Hilfe weltweit darauf
können wir stolz sein meine Damen und
Herren die Welt kann sich auch weiterhin
auf Deutschland verlassen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger können sich auf
diese Ampelkoalition verlassen
[Applaus]
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun Jürgen Trittin das Wort als
außenpolitischer Sprecher der Bündnis
grünen Fraktion frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren ich glaube wir müssen
uns klarmachen dass die Grenzen zwischen
innen und Außenpolitik zunehmend
verschwinden man kann es kaum noch
trennen in vielen Fragen das erfordert
auch für tradierte Außenpolitik
teilweise neue Erfahrungen und neue
Lösung und wenn man dann noch hin
zunimmt dass wir nicht mit einer Krise
uns auseinandersetzen sondern mit drei
globalen großkrisen parallel die sich
auch noch in ihren Wirkungen gegenseitig
verstärken Corona Klimakrise und der
Bruch der europäischen
sicherheitsordnung durch Putin da kann
man das an dieser Stelle einfach
durchbuchstabieren die corona-politik in
China führt dazu dass die Globalisierung
wie sie bisher gewesen ist nicht mehr
funktioniert wir brauchen andere
Antworten in der Handelspolitik da drauf
und wir stellen alle gemeinsam fest die
Außenministerin hat das beschrieben dass
die Frage ob es Putin gelingt
durchzukommen nicht allein davon abhängt
dass wir zügig und ordentlich die
Ukraine mit Waffen ausstatten sondern
die Durchhaltefähigkeit in diesem
globalen Konflikt wird auch darüber
entschieden dass wir in Deutschland aber
auch global für Gerechtigkeit und für
eine gerechte Verteilung der
lastensorgen so passen plötzlich innen
und Außenpolitik zusammen und das
gleiche gilt für die Klimakrise die
Klimakrise hat nicht nur die Regierung
in Sri Lanka sozusagen aus dem Amt
hinweggefegt
sie macht uns auch gerade vor durch die
Pegelstände an der Rhone und anderswo
das Atomkraft in ganz dummes Rezept ist
um Versorgungssicherheit herzustellen
und auf diese Herausforderung muss die
neue nationale Sicherheitsstrategie eine
Antwort geben und wir haben uns damit ja
auch eine Grundlage gegeben in der
Koalitionsvereinbarung weil wir gesagt
haben wir gehen von einem erweiterten
Sicherheitsbegriff aus das heißt wenn
wir über Hybride Kriegsführung sprechen
dann müssen wir auch darüber sprechen
wie man zum Beispiel Cyber-Attacken hier
bekämpft das wird nicht nur das
Innenministerium alleine machen können
aber wir haben in dieser
Koalitionsvereinbarung auch festgelegt
dass das mit ordentlichen Mitteln
unterlegt wird und wenn ich die von
Ihnen genannte eins zu eins-regelung
zugrunde lege dann stelle ich fest dass
in diesem Haushalt das Defizit zur eins
zu eins-regelung gegenüber dem letzten
Haushalt nicht kleiner sein größer
geworden ist sie beträgt 5,5 Milliarden
und allein im Auswärtigen Amt ist für
die humanitäre Hilfe eine halbe
Milliarde weniger vorgesehen glaubt denn
jemand dass wir damit auskommen werden
nein nicht mal die Regierung glaubt das
die hat nämlich gerade beschlossen
2022 aus haushaltsrechten genau diese
halbe Milliarde wieder in einzusetzen
und deswegen sage ich wir werden hier
eine sehr anregende Debatte in den
Fachausschüssen im Haushaltsausschuss zu
diesem Einzelplan haben und ich will bei
der Gelegenheit an meinen Freund und
Kollegen Peter Struck erinnern
der war nicht nur einer der besten
Verteidigungsminister die dieses Land
hier hatte er hat auch das strucksche
Gesetz erfunden wonach kein Gesetz so
aus dem Bundestag rausgeht wie es
reingegangen ist das wird auch für
diesen Haushaltsentwurf des Einzelplans
nur fünf gelten
er sagt für Jürgen Trittin eine
anregende Debatte was diese einzelplanen
anbeling anbelangt das Gefühl
tatsächlich kann man nach der bisherigen
Aussprache zu diesem Einzelplan durchaus
haben dabei ist das reinvolumenmäßig
einer der kleineren etas in der
Haushaltssystematik von den Ausgaben
geplant 6,4 Milliarden Euro
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
seit über einem halben Jahr führt
Russland einen mörderischen
Vernichtungskrieg gegen die Ukraine das
Projekt unsere Außenpolitik dieser
russische Angriff ist ein Angriff auf
die europäische Friedensordnung es ist
ein Angriff auch auf unsere Freiheit
auch auf unsere Sicherheit der Krieg und
die Auswirkungen auf unser Land auf
Europa auf die Menschen hier aber
genauso auf das Leid in der Ukraine
beschäftigen uns alle hier in diesem
Haus jeden Tag und eben auch die
zentrale Frage tut Deutschland tun wir
genug und diesen Krieg schnellstmöglich
zu beenden und die Antwort ist nein
meine Damen und Herren und das wird auch
durch
das Blendwerk des Bundeskanzlers von
heute morgen nicht anders denn
Flugabwehr zum Beispiel ist natürlich
eine gute Sache aber die wird im
nächsten Jahr geliefert wir müssen jetzt
mehr tun und wir können jetzt mehr tun
es wird verzögert vertröstet dem
ukrainischen Regierungschef einfach eine
Abfuhr erteilt Marder und Leopard lieber
Bau von der Industrie retten jetzt heute
morgen leben und werden einfach
verweigert und es ist keine Kritik meine
Damen und Herren die ich hier als
Oppositionspolitiker Vortrage weil es
meine Rolle ist dass wir mehr tun
könnten ist das Bild des unsere
osteuropäischen Nachbarn zeichnen dass
unsere englischen Freunde zeichnen das
durch viele Statistiken belegt ist und
meine Damen und Herren das ist eine
Position die auch viele Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in den ampelparteien Teilen und
deshalb tut es weh wenn in so einer
wichtigen Frage Anspruch und
Wirklichkeit reden und Hand in diesem
Fall des Kanzlers so weit auseinander
stehen
Frau Bundesministerin ihnen tut diese
Blockade aus dem Kanzleramt sicherlich
auch wie weil sie diesen Krieg
richtigerweise in das große Bild
einordnen Demokratie Freiheit gegen
Autokratie und Diktatur eine Ordnung die
auf Regeln basiert gegen das Recht der
stärkeren und größeren demokratische
Systeme sind im Bedrängnis wir sind in
Bedrängnis Autokraten weltweit suchen
den Schulterschluss Russland und China
bauen ihren Einfluss in vielen Regionen
der Welt aus und nutzen dafür jede
Möglichkeit aber was stellen wir denn
dem entgegen
Tatkraft
Verlässlichkeit
da haben wir noch eine Aufgabe Frau
bundesministerinnen Afghanistan mit den
ortskräften
bessere Kommunikation und ein noch
intensiveres hineinwirken in
Zivilgesellschaften ein noch
intensiveres werden für unsere Werte und
Überzeugungen und ich bin froh Frau
Ministerin dass sie der Bedeutung
zivilgesellschaftlicher Zusammenarbeit
auch bei ihren reichen Reisen immer
wieder auch sehr viel Raum einräumen und
dieses Engagement auswärtiger Kultur-
und Bildungspolitik entsprechend auch
Rechnung tragen aber deshalb muss die
Frage erlaubt sein weil warum gerade in
diesem Haushaltsentwurf akbp und viele
weitere Bereiche empfindliche Kürzungen
hinnehmen müssen wieder einmaligen
Anspruch und Wirklichkeit meilenweit
auseinander denn der Kahlschlag im
Bereich akpp wäre wirklich völlig
unverständlich wollen sie in dieser Zeit
wirklich tausende Stipendien beim
akademischen Austauschdienst streichen
wo Verbindungen zu unserem Land ent die
Jahrzehnte halten wollen Sie wirklich
gute Institute schließen Anlaufstelle
für alle die sich für unser Land für
unsere Sprache interessieren aber auch
für die die in totalitären staatenraum
für freie Gedanken brauchen wollen sie
alles verwerfen was wir in den letzten
Jahren beim archäologischen deutschen
analogischen Institut aufgebaut haben
zum Kulturerhalt den Krisenregionen es
sind nur drei Beispiele Auslandsschulen
das Netzwerk ist groß und verdient es
auch eine solide und verlässliche
Finanzierung zu haben
sollte es
sollte es wirklich Tradition werden dass
immer wenn das Außenministerium von den
Grünen geführt wird ein Kahlschlag bei
der internationalen Kultur und
Bildungspolitik erfolgt ich glaube es
ist nicht in unserem Interesse und
deshalb bitte ich die Haushälter der
Ampel hier und wirklich massiv
nachzubessern weil sonst eben wirklich
wieder Worte und Taten bei dieser
Regierung weit auseinander liegen würden
wie zuletzt auch bei der europarede des
Kanzlers in frag sichtbar wurde der
Kanzler fordertee ein souveräneres
Europa und dazu würde es aber eine
Bundesregierung benötigen die bereit ist
eine außenkritische Führungsrolle in
Europa anzunehmen wir brauchen kein
Europa der schönen Worte sondern ein
Europa der konkreten Tat und da muss
diese Bundesregierung auch in diesem
Haushalt deutlich mehr liefern
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort hat Michelle Müntefering für
die SPD sie sitzt im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss des Bundestages frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Welt ordnet sich neu das ist ohne
Zweifel wir haben es gehört auch für uns
in Deutschland eine riesengroße
Herausforderung im Ruhrgebiet war es in
diesem Sommer immer wieder waren es
immer die zwei Themen die viele
umtreiben zum einen der brutale Angriff
Russlands auf die Ukraine und die Sorge
nach den rasant steigenden Energiekosten
allerdings auch war nicht immer in
dieser Reihenfolge die Menschen
schreiben uns Briefe diejenigen die
sonst nie sich an Politik wenden
Rentnerinnen formulieren ihre Angst die
Wohnung zu verlieren schreiben akribisch
jeder Aufgabe aus fragen wir Sie die
Kosten in Zukunft noch stemmen sollen
und viele Unternehmen fragen wie sie zu
wettbewerbsfähigen Preisen ihre Waren
produzieren sollen wenn die Energie
immer teurer wird deswegen bevor ich zum
Haushalt des Auswärtigen Amtes komme
möchte ich zunächst einmal all
denjenigen danke sagen die helfen durch
diese schwere Zeit zu kommen ob als
Abgeordnete in den Wahlkreisen in der
Koalition
die dringend benötigten Entschlüsse
fassen und ganz besonders natürlich
unseren Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
ja der Krieg kostet uns Geld die
Menschen in der Ukraine kostet er das
Leben liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen als
außenpolitikerin war ich in der
Sommerpause nicht auf Dienstreise im
Ausland sondern diesmal vor allem in der
Nachbarschaft unterwegs zu anderen zu
Besuch bei Evonik einem der
international für einen Unternehmen in
der Spezialchemie und ich will den Bogen
vom Ruhrgebiet in die Welt schlagen weil
mitten in meinem Wahlkreis die
Beschichtungen für die Windräder
hergestellt werden und oft vergessen
wird für die Transformation der
Wirtschaft brauchen wir auch eine starke
Chemie Klimawandel Energiekrise alles
was in der Welt passiert hat eben auch
mit uns in Deutschland zu tun und
deswegen hat übrigens gerade der
Vorstandsvorsitzende von Evonik
Christian Kohlmann mit weiteren
Vorsitzenden von Unternehmen einen
Appell an die bundesaußenministerin
Annalena baerburg geschickt in dem
erfordert dass insbesondere die
auswärtige und Bildungspolitik mit mehr
Geld ausgestattet werden muss und die
geplanten Kürzungen zurückgenommen
werden sollen denn Deutschland ist auch
massiv angewiesen auf Fachkräfte auf
gute Ausbildung hier bei uns und auf
internationale Kräfte wir sind zusammen
stark und deswegen brauchen wir die
Goethe-Institute die Deutschkurse
anbieten wo die Menschen sind die
Auslandsschulen die junge Menschen früh
an unser Land binden den DAAD die
Humboldt-Stiftung die Forschung
unterstützen weltweit und auf Spitzen
Niveau für Fortschritt Arbeitsplätze und
Verständigung Arbeiten liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen deutschland muss sich
gerade heute im Wandel der Welt um neue
Partnerschaften bemühen wir brauchen
neben Europa auch Afrika Asien und
Lateinamerika um den größeren großen
Herausforderungen zu begegnen und es ist
längst nicht gesagt dass ich ein
Großteil der Weltgemeinschaft unseren
Vorstellungen und Überzeugungen
anschließ es ist an uns für die
Demokratie als Staats- und Lebensform zu
wirken und dafür brauchen wir auch die
Unterstützung der Zivilgesellschaften
die zunehmende Ungewissheit als
Grundgefühl ist weder ein lokales noch
regionales Phänomen und besonders die
jungen Generationen auf diesem Planeten
erleben die rasanten der rasanten
Veränderungen auf der ganzen Welt mit
voller Wucht und zwar aus zwei
Perspektiven die einen wollen ihren
Wohlstand nicht verlieren die anderen
wollen überhaupt welchen haben und das
ist im übertragenen Sinne die
ungleichseitigkeit des gleichzeitigen
und umso mehr brauchen wir gemeinsame
Lösungen die Macht verteilt sich neu und
in so einer Situation dürfen wir doch
nicht zusehen wie China immer mehr
konfuzius-institute eröffnet und als
Antwort auch noch deutsche Strukturen
zerschlagen Kultur Jugend
wissenschaftsaustausch zurückfahren
Sprachkurse und Unterstützung für die
Zivilgesellschaft kürzen das wäre
Wuppertal und das alles
das alles ist auch eine Frage der
Langfristigkeit denn hier gilt besonders
diese Strukturen die wirken über
Jahrzehnte Kultur
kann man nicht einfach auf und abbauen
Kultur ist kein Camping kein Zelt
sondern die mittlerorganisation und
ihren ihre Mitarbeiter die Arbeiten über
Jahre hinweg und deswegen will ich denen
auch allen danken die für eine
werteorientierte Außenpolitik eintreten
denn davon darf man nicht nur reden man
muss sie vor allen Dingen vermitteln und
machen und Liebe Annalena baerbock das
muss ihr Haus unter grüner Führung noch
unter Beweis stellen uns haben sie dabei
an Ihrer Seite wenn ich ihre Worte
richtig verstanden habe müsste das dann
aber auch am Ende die Konsequenz sein
ich kann nur sagen lassen Sie uns das
Verändern an dieser Stelle die Fachleute
im Bundestag sind sich einig wir haben
das hier auch gerade gehört und bitte
kümmern Sie sich auch gleichzeitig um
die Ausstattung der visastellen sonst
können wir natürlich lange über gute
Fachkräfte Reden an kaum tun die dann
hier nicht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich bin überzeugt Deutschland
wird in diesen globalen Wettbewerb nur
mit klarer Ausrichtung an den
Zukunftsthemen bestehen können davon
hängt zu einem beträchtlichen Teil die
Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Lebens und
wohlstandsmodells ab und wer hier
mutwillig spart der begibt sich auf eine
außenpolitische Geisterfahrt entgegen
aller Vernunft
Michelle Müntefering war das für die
SPD-Fraktion sieht sie im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss und jetzt hören wir noch mal
einen Haushälter für die FDP der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher Otto Fricke
als neuer berichterstatte für den
Einzelplan hört man solchen Debatten
sehr interessiert zu was mich so ein
bisschen überrascht hat als jemand der
Jurist von Hauses ist ein Haushälter ist
dann wenn man doch feststellt wie links
und rechts eigentlich die gleichen
Meinungen in der Außenpolitik sind wenn
herr Gysi sagt ohne Russland ist Frieden
nicht möglich die AFD das bestätigt
komme ich als kleiner Geschichte
leistungskursmensch daran dass ich mich
erinnere dass es mal einen Menschen mit
Vornamen Neville gehabt der gesagt hat
ohne dieses oder jene Land ist Frieden
nicht möglich und wo das 1945 hingeführt
hat weil man diese glaubt unglaubwürdige
Idee hatte man meinte man könnte solchen
Menschen Grenzen über
Friedensverhandlungen aufzeigen das
wissen wir doch alle und daran sieht man
dass es gut ist dass sie beide nicht an
der Regierung sind meine Damen und
Herren
wir werden in diesem Einzelhandel stimmt
den Kollegen Trittin zu werden wir sehr
intensive Beratung haben auf jeden Fall
aber ich will doch zu den Zahlen noch
mal etwas sagen erstens die Verfassung
gilt die Schuldenbremse geht und ich bin
auch sehr dankbar der Koalitionsrunde
dass sie noch mal aus
drücklich halten hat dass die
Finanzplanung für das Jahr 23 inklusive
der Schuldenbremse gilt da steht ja auch
so in den Papier drin dennoch glaube ich
müssen wir mal ein paar klagen zahlen
hier Klarheiten ich sage das auch in
Richtung CDU und ich sage das auch für
die gesamten Haushaltsberatungen lasst
uns doch in den Wettbewerb gehen zeigt
mal was ihr drauf habt macht
Änderungsanträge sagt wo ihr mehr
ausgeben wollt sagt wo ihr das Geld her
haben wollt eure Rede sei ja nein nein
und nicht ja ich will es als
Außenpolitiker nein im Haushalt
beantrage ich nicht mehr und dann gucken
wir mal ob da gute Vorschläge dabei sind
wir werden unsere Veränderungsvorschläge
dann dagegen setzen und sehen was die
beste Lösung für die deutsche
Außenpolitik und damit auch für die
europäische Außenpolitik und wegen
unserer Führungsposition für die gesamte
Welt dann auch sein wird ich bin sehr
gespannt darauf was ihr da machen werdet
seit cdu/cs zu den Zahlen
Gewinnzahlen es hat mal eine kluge Frau
oder ein kluger Mann gesagt Erfolg
darfst du nicht nur daran messen was du
erreicht hast sondern auch wie du dahin
gekommen bist und dann habe ich mir
gelegt okay gut der Haushalt sagt dem
soll als Vorschlag der Bundesregierung
wir im Parlament entscheiden die
schlagen vor wir entscheiden sagt 6,39
Milliarden im nächsten Jahr dann habe
ich gesagt ja gut okay das ist weniger
als im letzten Jahr war aber auch eine
Sondersituation denn ich naja dann
vergleichst du das doch mal damit was
als letztes die große Koalition und der
Führung einer christdemokratischen
Kanzlerin vorgeschlagen hat habe ich
nachgelesen und da steht dann festhalten
5,03 Milliarden 25 prozentige Steigerung
also dieser Koalition gegenüber dem was
die cdu/csu als sie noch in der
Regierung war für dieses Jahr geplant
hat daran zeigt sich wo man hinkommen
will wenn man in der Außenpolitik Erfolg
haben will zweitens dann gehen sie auch
nur hin und gucken auf diese kleine Zahl
und ich empfehle den Außenpolitiker mal
mehr mit ihren sehr klugen sehr
fleißigen Haus zu reden dass man einen
auswärtigen Haushalt nicht nur aus dem
Einzelplan 05 sehen muss sondern sie man
muss wie der Kollege Trittin das auch
gemacht hat sowohl im Jahr 1900 2022 für
die Frage wie helfen wir im Bereich
Ernährung sehen dass da eine Milliarde
dazu kommt für 23 und 5 und genauso muss
man sehen dass wir verstärkungsmittel
nach der Planung der Bundesregierung im
Einzelplan 60 in Höhe von 5 Milliarden
Euro haben und wir werden uns auch da
genau angucken was lassen wir in dem
Einzelplan 60 was kommt bei des
konkretisieren können in den
einzelplanbereich 5 wir werden uns
anschauen was bei der humanitären Hilfe
notwendig ist weil wir nicht genau
wissen was passiert deswegen wenn wir in
der Haushaltspolitik im Bereich des
einzelplanes 5 ernst nehmen dann können
wir nicht nur eine bauchnabelschau
betreiben sondern dann müssen wir den
gesamten Haushalt sehen und müssen
insgesamt sehen was wir machen denn es
ist wie wir immer wieder als FDP sagen
Defense diplomessie und die Wellem and a
das sind die 3DS die wir immer insgesamt
sehen darüber müssen wir den
Haushaltsberatung reden und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass da am Ende ein noch
mal besseres Ergebnis rauskommt immer
jedoch ein besseres Ergebnis als das was
sie ursprünglich in der Planung haben
meine Damen und Herren zum nächsten
Punkt
ich will nur mal festhalten die Planung
im Haushalt wird so vorgelegt dass die
Eckpunkte vom Kabinett beschlossen
werden dann werden sie von den
jeweiligen Fachministerien aufgefüllt
und die gehen so dann ins Kabinett ins
Kabinett beschließt wie auch hier
gemeinsam den Einzelplan das ist jetzt
der Vorschlag so wie er vom
Fachministerium im Rahmen in dem
Gesetzen Rahmen gemacht wird wie ist das
Kabinett beschlossen hat die Details
können wir dann ändern ich bin
wahnsinnig gespannt darauf welche
Vorschläge kommen werden aus allen
Richtungen ich will aber eines deutlich
sagen ich habe als Hausherr gedacht so
jetzt arbeite ich mich da ein ich lese
das durch ich schaue die Entwicklung an
ich schaue mir die Erläuterung an und
ich möchte aber jetzt auch mal wissen
wie ist das eigentlich in den einzelnen
Ländern denn wir haben ja ausdrücklich
im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten und
das möchte ich den Koalitionären noch
mal sagen wir wollen eine Umstellung auf
eine ziel- und wirkungsorientierte
Haushaltsführung dazu muss ich aber
erstmal wissen was ich in das jeweilige
Land an Leistungen gebe und diese
countrifights die habe ich nicht und da
sage ich als Haushälter ganz deutlich
die will ich haben ich habe so das
Gefühl Außenministerin weil sie ja auch
gezeigt haben dass sie da wo es
notwendig ist eine Ministerin der klaren
Aussprache sind dass ich da von ihnen
Unterstützung mit meiner Fraktion
bekomme und ich hoffe dass wir dann am
Ende der Beratung sagen können es war
ein guter Haushaltsberatungen aber wir
haben Goethe in seinem Sonett
berücksichtigt in der Beschränkung zeigt
sich der Meister herzlichen Dank
so Fricke mit einem kleinen Zitat und
vor allem mit einem Exkurs zur
Haushaltssystematik für die
cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun ja doch eine
sehr besondere ist und auch eine sehr
komplizierte
da kann man dann noch mal nachfragen und
die Ministerinnen doch um einiges bitten
bzw das Haus
kassenkörper für die Union zweiten Mal
in diesem Jahr starten wir in
Haushaltsberatungen und auch die
jetzigen Beratungen stehen ganz im
Zeichen des ukrainings was die Ukraine
in diesen Krieg erleiden müssen können
wir uns wohl nur schwer vorstellen aber
auch für den Rest der Welt und auch für
uns sind die Folgen bereits spürbar
teils dramatisch politisch
wirtschaftlich aber auch
gesellschaftlich und das wird sich meine
Vorredner hatten das auch schon erwähnt
das wird sich natürlich auf unsere
Beratungen auswirken diese
Haushaltsberatung werden die
schwierigsten Beratungen seit
Jahrzehnten werden
für die Folgen die Folgen dieses Krieges
zum Beispiel die höchste Inflation seit
50 Jahren die spürt mittlerweile jeder
hier im Land ob an der Kasse im
Supermarkt oder an der Zapfsäule und
noch dramatischer allerdings ist die
Situation der Preisentwicklung bei Strom
und Gas sparen ist also das Gebot der
Stunde das gilt für alle für
Privatpersonen für die Wirtschaft aber
auch für den Staat und diese
Notwendigkeit macht auch vor dem
Bundeshaushalt nicht halt
wer heute noch einer expansiven
schuldenfinanzierten Ausgabenpolitik das
Wort redet der hatte wohl noch keine
Gelegenheit in den letzten Bericht des
Bundesrechnungshof einen Blick zu werfen
der Rechnungshof kommt zu dem
ernüchternden Ergebnis dass die
finanzielle Handlungsfähigkeit des
Bundes massiv gefährdet ist
die nötigen Schlussfolgerungen daraus
können nur als mindestens einschneidend
wenn nicht sogar dramatisch bezeichnet
werden die Aufgabe uns ist klar wir
müssen uns zunehmend auf die
verfassungsmäßigen Kernaufgaben des
Bundes fokussieren und wir müssen und da
bin ich bei Ihnen Frau Ministerin sie
hatten das in ihrer Rede auch erwähnt
wir müssen die Kraft haben politisch zu
priorisieren denn den Realitäten wie sie
der Rechnungshof benennt müssen wir uns
stellen diesen Realitäten muss diese
Bundesregierung sich stellen das ist die
haushaltspolitische Kernbotschaft dieser
Tage
und vielen Finanzminister Lindner will
mit diesem Haushaltsentwurf den
richtigen Weg gehen und ich hoffe dass
Ihnen seine mit Koalitionäre auch diesen
Weg gehen lassen es ist richtig mit
diesem Haushalt den Versuch zu
unternehmen nach drei Jahren wieder in
die haushaltspolitische Realität
zurückzukehren und die Schuldenregel
einzuhalten und deshalb sehen sie mich
heute hier stehen und ich erhebe keine
Mehrforderungen
Ukraine Krug keine Krieg und abflauender
Konjunktur zum Trotz verzeichnet ja der
Staat gesamtstaatlich Rekordeinnahmen in
diesem Jahr und da muss es auch der
ampelregierung in dieser schwierigen
Situation möglich sein die
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten immerhin man
hat reagiert im BMF und das sieht man
auch am Einzelplan 05 des Auswärtigen
Amtes dieser sinkt zum
Vorjahresvergleich um ungefähr zehn
Prozent das ist der gleiche Prozentsatz
in dem der 23er Haushalt insgesamt auch
sinkt und eine Hoffnung für das
Auswärtige Amt Frau Ministerin ist
natürlich in dieser Situation noch der
Einzelplan 60 dort hat der BMF fünf
Milliarden eingestellt zur Deckung
eventueller Mehrbedarfe in den
Einzelplänen
eine Frau Schulze hat fürs BMZ da schon
die Hand gehoben dass sie dafür was
benötigt und trotzdem muss ich die
Vorgehensweise des BMF an dieser Stelle
kritisieren mit haushaltsklarheit und
haushaltswahrheit hat das nichts zu tun
ich würde mir wünschen dass in den
Haushaltsberatungen so viel wie möglich
aus dem Einzelplan 60 konkret in die
Einzelpläne geht damit der Haushalt
nicht an Aussagekraft verliert und es
ist bemerkenswert wirklich
außerordentlich bemerkenswert für mich
dass eben die Bundesregierung im
Einzelplan 5 ausgerechnet im Bereich der
humanitären Hilfe kürzt von zweieinhalb
Milliarden ungefähr auf zwei Milliarden
das sind 20 Prozent weniger genau dort
wo er in der aktuellen Situation die Not
am größten ist aber dort ist eben auch
die Chance am größten im
parlamentarischen Verfahren den aufwuchs
zu bekommen dieses Spiel ist natürlich
durchschaubar und hat mit seriöser
Haushaltspolitik nicht viel zu tun
zwei Punkte möchte ich noch ansprechen
und lieber Otto da sind wir gar nicht so
weit auseinander zum einen möchte ich
mal feststellen dass das Personal an
unseren Auslandsvertretungen ohne jeden
Zweifel immer die bestmöglichen
Arbeitsbedingungen vorfinden muss da
gibt es wohl im Haus kein Zweifel drüber
aber ich glaube wir sollten die Frage
diskutieren ob es denn immer zwingend
nötig ist dass zum Beispiel die
Botschaftsgebäude in Chile oder in
Norwegen immer nach deutschem Standard
geplant und gebaut werden müssen hier
sind sicherlich Einsparpotenziale zu
heben und als letzten Punkt der mir
wirklich am Herzen liegt und Otto du
hast es angesprochen ich hoffe dass wir
in diesen Haushaltsverhandlungen endlich
beim Thema länderdatenbank auf
Knopfdruck einen Schritt weiterkommen
das ist ein Thema das beschäftigt im
schon lang ich habe den Eindruck dass
das Auswärtige Amt das will dass das
Auswärtige Amt auch in der Lage ist das
zu tun das BMZ hat in den letzten Jahren
bewiesen dass sie nicht in der Lage sind
ich hoffe hier dass wir das ins Ziel
bekommen und ich freue mich auf
spannende und herausfordernde Beratungen
in den nächsten Wochen vielen Dank
[Applaus]